well we are back with a live look at
Capitol Hill where lawmakers and White
House officials are meeting in less than
two hours Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
Steve manoosh and Speaker Nancy Pelosi
and Kevin McCarthy working to hash out
details of a 1 trillion dollar
coronavirus relief package it is
expected to include financial relief for
American workers and small businesses a
final vote scheduled for tomorrow and
with that we bring in South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham chairman of the
Senate Judiciary Committee senator
Graham is always a pleasure and closer
we very close and if we don't do this
you should all come up here and kick us
in the back fingers not option we're
going to pass a bill Monday it's going
to help people who've lost our paychecks
to get income it's going to help
hospitals who've been overrun with money
to get through this and it's going to
help increase medical supplies and
stabilize the economy we're fighting a
two-front war one is the virus itself
the other is the economy that's been
locked down because of containment
policies which in your mind senator as
you look at this bill which war is more
important not that you necessarily have
to choose between the two what do you
kind of do and so ultimately if it's a
two trillion dollar bill if you go
all-in on the war to prevent everyone
from getting sick and you shut the
economy down for two months you've got a
different kind of war there where are
you on that balance the virus is Germany
and the economy is Japan so we're buying
time in this bill we're paying for
containment we're trying to lower the
infection rate and here's what I believe
if we did nothing over two million
Americans would die from the virus
half the population would be in effect
would be infected and you'd have a
mortality rate around one percent plus
if you act decisively and have
aggressive containment policies we stop
the infection from spreading until we
can get therapies and vaccines to kill
this damn thing so my number one goal is
to go all-in on the health care front to
find therapies and vaccines sooner
rather than
lair later to kill the virus and lessens
its effect on people and the economy
locked down is to buy time to accomplish
that you know senator so many people
want so many answers to this you know
you talk about finding a vaccine and you
talk about you know getting people that
the money that they really need right
now for those people at home who are in
need of help who are sitting here
watching can you give us a glimpse of
behind the scenes what exactly is going
on to try and make that happen well
number one we all agree up here that a
small business there 1,700 restaurants
in Myrtle Beach all armed are shut down
because of containment policies we're
going to ask the business owners to go
to the bank and get a loan and pay their
employees up to 80,000 in salary pay the
mortgage paid the rent payment and we'll
forgive six weeks of it and hopefully we
wouldn't get this behind us we're going
to increase dramatically unemployment
insurance available to people the most
you can get in South Carolina is three
hundred and twenty six dollars a week
we're going to dramatically increase
that because that's not enough to live
on and major companies who are otherwise
healthy have no business we're going to
float them loans until they get through
this we're going to relieve student debt
burden by saying you don't have to pay
your student loan for six months we're
gonna take burns off of people get their
paychecks stabilized and as to the virus
we're going to give a lot of money to
hospitals so they don't get overwhelmed
senator let's delve into one of the
things you said we're not talking about
the the Myrtle Beach establishments I'm
not talking about having any government
intervention aside from the money that
they're gonna get but you did mention
the big corporations and you did mention
loans to those big corporations earlier
on the show we had your colleague
senator Scott from Florida on and when I
asked him should the government you know
non-voting but but financially get us
get some sort of stock in these
companies because of the money that
they're giving you dan I'm focusing on
the big companies he said yes the
government should make some money off of
the investment that they're putting in
these companies to help pay for this on
the back end do you agree well I think
it should be loans not grants I don't
pretend to know how to make money off
all this but I just don't want companies
to get grants like Boeing Boeing the 787
which is the premier
wide-body jet in the world is made in
Charleston South Carolina the 737 max
has been a disaster I don't want to bail
out Boeing because of the 737 problem
but if we don't help Bo and keep the 787
production line in being we're going to
give the entire war market to Airbus I
promise you the Europeans are not gonna
let Airbus fail so what I'm trying to do
is make sure that big corporations get
loans not grants so they can get through
this I'm trying to make sure individuals
who's lost their paycheck they get an
income stream beginning this week
senator you know most Americans right
now worried about their income their
jobs and yes there are predictions right
now showing that this coronavirus could
trigger a downturn costing up to 5
million US jobs I mean where do we go
from there well I don't even believe
this 5 million I believe 70% of the
economy is shut down simply because you
can't be around 10 people as long as we
have a containment policy that you
should hunker down in place and
California New York imagine how that
affects the economy you got the two
largest states in the Union basically
shut down that affects all of us as long
as we say as a nation